how's it going BR my name is shut up I'm
doing my intro over here Mr bed or
whatever you are all right so I dug
welcome back to cry fear I dug up the
key in this one I don't know if it's uh
look at this I'm going to do some MLG
stuff right here oh this is going to be
epic bam oh wait wait okay I can do it I
can't shoot while I jump well isn't that
a shame all right I see you mister let
me just hard scope you little [__] and
one two
bam did I get him I don't know I'm not
sure let's watch police Bill police bill
I you are you trying to stand in my way
police Bill no are you don't tell me are
you do you know are you working with the
barel no it's impossible police B police
Bill I'm trying to save the world here
police B oh let me ride you police well
let me ride you tonight and I'll make
you feel all right hey shovel what are
you doing there I don't remember
dropping you all right we have to quick
scope that little [__] where is he
come here buddy I'll quick scope you
like a ba for you had MLG [__] oh son
you just got pooped on [__] MLG 360 oh
yeah oh yeah oh yeah he mad he's so mad
he's crying to with Mama all right
that's not his problem hey what are you
doing up there stop sleeping you're not
supposed to sleep like that huh who told
you to sleep like that sure as hell it
wasn't me huh huh all right fine you're
a bed now regular bed M I can sleep now
I sleep on you whoa what the hell that's
uncomfortable what the hell dude dude
seriously H I don't even know anymore
all right so um police Bill police Bill
are they hugging you police Bill you're
just a cuddly guy aren't you police B
okay let's unlock here and go in here on
the amamos AL um I don't I don't know I
don't know where we going were we going
to a rooftop if I don't remember wrong
cuz a girl call us that's what usually
happens the ladies are like hey [__]
when can we use this stupid bicycle I
want it and I want it now can we go in
here of course not it won't budge taking
it for elevator doesn't work nothing is
stupid lamp it's all your fault I blame
everything on you what's this
garbage can we what is that I hear
something
hello can we go in here Sanson Sanson
never at home always out drinking hey
magazines lovely oh we can go in here
awesome Fen
on Fone oh what is
this I have a hoodie but I can't see it
s likes to place us it's a m card going
to shopping a cop what I can't pick up
the cup all right let's save here
because I mean why not cop why won't you
pick up o look at this regular day in
Stockholm climb out windows say hi to
police Bill police bill number 25 all
right let's be on our way over here oh I
have to jump here all right let me
charge it let me charge it and I W bam
that's what you get for I don't know
something all right let's climb up here
and snipe some lades on the roof she
better be here I mean I came all this
way for a hot date all right so there or
ha probably ha okay what do we have here
M16 what when the hell did we get an M
where's my M16 girl where's my M16 whoa
what are you doing there I'm taking your
Facebook po picture oh you're so angry
all right I don't like those little
[__] let me shoot him let me end your
mystery don't you worry I can't see
anything H whatever are you dead bro
you're supposed to be dead is he dead
all right got to shake him got to poke
him give him a little poke and then you
know if they the actual day T night 360
[__] yeah all right you
dead uh he's pretty dead I think all
right finish all his stuff here whoa
what are you doing there anyone tell you
to go there oh no snap back off you
little [__] oh back off that's what
you get I didn't mean to kill you but
you were just standing there and I was
like no back off but he didn't back off
that's what you get another epic jump
what oh no another bed God damn it they
just never [__] stop do they all
right it's time for MLG quick scoping
time
where the [__] did he go whoa where'd he
go hey oh what are you doing bed aren't
supposed to move I TR to get I'm sorry
I'm sorry but you're not a regular bed
with a lot of period on it okay I think
whoa whoa whoa let's not this is
dangerous I you just sometimes you just
got to jum
no God damn it why did I save first time
to jump like a b all right actually did
jump like box of shells my shotgun I
missed that baby all right let's be
careful
here there we go there we go papa py
papa py got this jumping like a boss
with a sniper rifle all right let's
climb up here hopefully there aren't any
scary things
hello why would they hang out on the
rooftop it makes no sense all right
let's go up here whoa what the hell
happened there what up I said the hell
oh there she is ah she wants me so what
the hell you doing she knows him well hi
Simon oh hi Simon what I don't what he
understood
before that you don't understand what do
you
think the whole [__] city is crawling
with monsters and I just it's your sex
appeal she just wants you that much you
just turn up on these rooftops
what are you doing here are you
hurt
monsters Simon Simon you need to take a
shell pill seriously
scar you got just got this is just sick
yes it is don't worry everything's going
to be all right I got this I got mg
quick scoping skill let's talk about
something else how have you been what I
said
problem uh I I don't don't
know how have you been been killing
monsters and died 50 million times and
she ah girl girl I'm pissed now thank
you better now that you're here what the
hell is she hitting on me of course she
is I mean I'm fabulous I'm glad you're
here too
Sophie Sophie alone all this
time I see sounds tough what the hell
but what about
yourself what why are you here yes good
question hiding up here from those
things what things no I really don't
understand what you're talking but what
are you doing here woman just us
thinking thinking about what woman
thinking yeah I've been doing a lot of
that
too girl do you remember how you got
here I don't
know because I woke up myself but it
wasn't an alley
and wait I can probably show you yes
no she's oh she's working with the
barrels and the police bill or this
police Bill I'm not sure about police
bill yet bro let's see I guess sure
let's
see
oh all right it's makeup time for last
time do you want to know something no
yes yes I do yes I do I want to know
just what in the [__] is going on here
good good good is it about that doctor
guy Dr Jones I don't like
him Simon please school no I mean about
school yeah
what well I don't know if you knew but I
always had a hard time at school cuz
you're [__] you were well you were
pretty much the only guy who was kind to
me he wasn't kind he just wanted to L
what thank you for making my life a
little bit more bearable you're a cute
guy cute guy Simon I see where this is
going I've seen
enough yeah you did have a I don't even
know thank you yeah now push her do it
push
her do it helped you because I liked you
oh were one of the prettiest girls at
school
and I don't know I just I wanted to get
laid I wanted to protect oh or that I
don't know I don't love you but I think
I could if we got to know each other
better you're so beautiful Sophie why
haven't you push her I never had the
courage I I
mean I wasn't exactly the toughest kid
in school was I but now we're here alone
I I
feel
stronger time to make a move buddy I've
always liked you Soph time to make a
move Simon enough talking I don't know
what to say enough [__] shat I always
liked you too but not in that
way
Deni push
her you just got pooped on son
oh oh he got friend zone poor guy poor
guy oh no this just how it is in life
sometimes damn so much stuff has
happened lately just push her down buddy
all this craziness the darkness and and
the
monsters I think I'm going crazy I think
so too I'm so glad I found you are you
sure about that cuz you just got denied
[__] don't go [__] what you
say was it you who tried to phone me by
the way yeah I wanted to talk to you to
get away from it all
oh but but what all here no away from
everything from all this all from
what what do you mean yes good question
girl boy you know full well what I mean
what wait a sec
you I know it you should have pushed her
what the
hell police man I saw that police man
what did you
do police
B police
[Music]
bill this isn't making any sense oh what
is it the bed again what the hell what
the hell is that he's on a balloon he's
like I'm
fabulous look at
me look at me look at my sex buddy I
kill her you sick [__] I'm working with
a police Bill no
don't work with the police carcass God
damn you're handsome holy [__] you're
beautiful let me take a photo you could
be on American's top no he threw in RoR
moms at me what the hell stop it I'm
hiding here stop it stop throwing room
moms at me
whoa ow they they Hur stop it
seriously what the hell what am I
supposed to do
here what what the hell am I supposed to
do you're dead you're not so fabulous
anymore are you son all right not so bad
not so bad not as no problem okay I'm
going to stay there all right how long
have I oh wait
okay where's my items huh police Bill
explain this [__] police Bill all
right I don't know what the [__] I did I
killed him somehow and um I guess we go
here and then over there and start our
away watch what are you doing don't
Dodge on my watch come on baby there we
go hey ammo for me Isn't that
fantastic I love ammo just as I love my
jumping I should be parkour I should be
a parkour Parish furnish I don't even
know what I said but I said something
and that's all right all right I'm
saving here cuz I doubt I'll make it I
don't even know if this is where I
should
go probably not cuz this is where I came
from isn't it police Bill what are you
doing
there all right so we are going back in
the room hey coffee cup I waited for you
baby well done thank you and we're going
to save here yep I'm stuck so I might as
well ended here all
right [__] oh no no I can't do lo oh no
Dad Dad shut up and do
it I'm alive I'm alive it's okay press
that Dad whatever you do don't press s
okay son I promise don't do it it's that
oh no oh no my Ops why did you press s